going back to
[Music]
when you were an agent seven years and
you're in it and you're seeing what's
going on
and both your perspective and your
wife's perspective so when you're laying
in bed and you guys are all talking to
each other and you guys are still
married to each other today so even
after you get out eight years later you
guys still chose to be married because
it's kind of tough when you get out life
is like a very different life so
um
okay so
when you went in
where did you
did any area of trust go higher you're
like oh man i used to have no respect
for those guys i got a lot of respect
for what those guys are doing you should
go in and say i never thought about
those guys damn those guys are dangerous
after seven years of being in
and then you went and you said oh those
are the guys that were studying those
guys are a hundred times more scary to
the world
than the media is even selling
and then the media yeah i used to really
trust the media used to say dude i don't
trust [ __ ] to say or i used to not trust
what the media is actually trust what
they have to say
what were some of the things where you
flipped where what you saw pre and now
you're on the inside what flipped on you
the biggest flip was media the he the
biggest flip out there was news i when i
started seeing what real intelligence
looks like
and how real intelligence is collected
how information is vetted and processed
and synthesized and turned into
something useful and then i would read
the news
i realize that the news is garbage like
the even the best news sources out there
the most centrist the most
highly rated news sources out there they
are still a far cry from what they were
in the 1950s when journalism was alive
when there were still laws in place that
forced you to have fair and balanced
news right now news news organizations
focus on feeding their audience base
that's what they do then if they get too
far off of their audience base then they
start to see a decrease in ratings and a
decrease in in ad revenue and they can't
have that especially not now that people
don't buy newspapers
so that was a massive flip for me some
of the other flips were the french
i went i was a military officer
you you were you were in the military
nobody says good things about the french
in the military we make fun of them all
the time right this is how the french go
to war right we make fun of them all the
time
you get into the intelligence service
the dgse is scary
they are so well funded they are so
technically adept they are hunting down
corporate and economic espionage secrets
are from us and we don't even know
they're there they are super powerful
had no idea that was happening no idea
at all and then you know mossad has a
reputation mossad is actually when you
deal with them in real life they're
pretty reasonable people they just have
the authority to do some crazy [ __ ]
compared to what we do in the united
states but generally speaking like you
sit down you have a beer with them like
you were saying about the trifecta right
you're justin timberlake they can dance
they can act they can sing right
you sit down with with a massage officer
and you're like you seem like a fair and
reasonable person
who is also protected by law
like unable to just kill somebody on the
spot i have to ask five levels up
whether or not i'm allowed to slap
somebody in the in the belly when
they're being interrogated in guantanamo
bay you know what i mean uh it's and
there's just so there's all sorts of
different things like that then i also
started to learn how scary terrorists
actually were
um you know the world knew about al
qaeda al al-qaeda by the time that al
qaeda was a mainstream thing al qaeda
wasn't actually that scary they did they
were well funded they had organization
and bureaucracy and reach but
bureaucracy slows you down
isis was terrifying isis is still in a
phase where it's recruiting what's known
as lone wolf terrorists lone wolves are
basically people they radicalize and
encourage to act and operate
independently and alone
so then there is no communication
channel anywhere of anybody saying hey
i'm going to hit this target this way
what do you think if there's no
communication there's no way to collect
intelligence these lone wolves can just
go out and do whatever they think
they're going to do and they've got the
permission of the organization and they
have you know the praise of the
caliphate behind them
that's scary stuff exactly what happened
with salman rushdie was a lone wolf and
his mother just disowned him did you see
what she said about him he just said
she's i can no longer support him being
my son
it's nuts that's that that world is a
terrifying world that the average
american has no idea let me ask you
because pat framed the question with
your perspective what has shifted you've
been pretty vocal about um
perception versus perspective right
getting out of your own shoes and
looking to the eyes of others he also
framed it with um you know what what you
said the media and you've been pretty
vocal about the perception perspective
we also talked about your wife how
when she kind of got red pilled into the
real world how she's went from being a
progressive liberal to being more center
same thing with you i assume is right
correct yeah yeah i mean you don't if
you're a super conservative you're not
trying to go to africa to like save
children right you're trying to build a
business or do something that that
boosts the economy in some way shape or
form so i we were both moved very very
very far to independent center once we
started realizing
not necessarily that there was like a
liberal narrative and it really
frustrates me when i hear people go off
the deep end about all these liberal
conspiracies and these liberal
narratives that the truth is
that liberals are just that that whole
media
is feeding its own base and it's feeding
a base of people who don't make a lot of
money who don't have a lot of education
who who are struggling to set themselves
up financially so they want to believe
that someone else should take care of
them and they want to believe that
someone else should help them and they
want to believe that they that a larger
big brother government should be on
their side but what ends up happening
across the board time and time again is
your 27 year old liberal becomes a 32
year old parent
with a career or a business and then
their perspective shifts because now
they got to protect what they have they
got to protect their family they got to
take care of their people they've got to
make sure that the future because now
there's a child
you've got to protect your child but you
also need a military to protect your
child so you know what if i have to pick
between who lives and who dies
my child lives somebody else dies so
you're like a living breathing case same
with your wife of you know the the
famous phrase if you're young and you're
not a liberal you have no heart and if
you're older and you're you're not a
conservative you have no brain is that
kind of what your process you went
through yeah it's like i mean those
every all of these idioms and all of
these uh all of these uh
stereotypes right they they happen for a
reason they happen because a normalized
statistically relevant number of people
start to follow in these certain trends
it doesn't mean it's right for everyone
but it's right for a majority of people
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]